when a person is addicted to porn  they are exactly where our culture wants  them to be  and how it wants them to be so as  already established porn tends to erode  your critical thinking skills your  powers of discernment and self-control  that is all advantageous to the left I  mean they love that porn isolates people  makes them lonely emotionally and  spiritually desolate and desperate  porn also obviously militates against  all of the Traditional Values which we  used to call virtues Chastity Temperance  patience humility all dwindle away  through porn consumption isolated  undiscerning lacking in self-control  lacking in critical thinking lonely and  temperate unchaste  that's how the left wants us  because for one thing it makes us easier  to control